As we did for Eclipse, and IDEs in general, we want
to start a GIT in a hands on way. So we're going
to start by seeing how to install GIT. And GIT is also
multiplatform, so you can install it no matter what operating system you
are using, unless of course you are using some arcane operating system.
But if you are using Linux, for instance, there should be a
package available that can install GIT for your specific distribution. If you're
using Mac OS, GIT is also available as part of XCode and
also as an independent package. Finally, if you're using Windows, GIT is
available as a package with an installer. In general, you can go
here to get information about how to get GIT, where to download
it, how to install it, and so on. So, now what I'd
like for you to do is to go, get GIT, install it,
in case you don't have it installed already on your machine. And
after that, you should be able to run GIT from the command
line. And, that's exactly what we're going to do through a demo.